here in burkina faso these delicate
plants are already sprouting later
they'll create a dense forest to stop
the spread of the Sahara Desert
Peter fun Midwood works for Berlin based
IT firm right now he's in Burkina Faso
to see if the trees are doing okay
his company is financing the
reforestation project this is a baobab I
know you are used to much bigger baobab
species are about
5,000 kilometers away in the Berlin
offices over cozier there's another
baobab sprouting Peter brought back some
seeds from Africa as a souvenir the IT
company is trying to generate as much
money as possible for reforestation
projects
I think trees are something very special
and trees are one of these things in
life that you only miss when they're
gone
so a lot of people in the Western world
they take trees for counters they're
nice for leisure and in nature and they
don't realize that they provide us with
water they provide us with many nuts
they provide us with timber is so many
things coming from it a cozia is a
search engine like Google or Bing the
site allows users to search for
information or products users see
advertising between the search results
when they click on it a cozia earns
money widgets founder Christian Cole
invests in trees
there are a few ads that are much more
valuable than than other ads so if you
search for I don't know buying a new
telephone or a car even then a click
could generate maybe even a few euros in
revenue for us which means there would
be a lot of trees just because of one
click most visitors to the site are from
France and Germany but consumers in the
US also turned to the search engine
users like being able to help the
environment with just one click around
80 percent of the revenue goes to eco
Xia's reforestation projects its
employees earn average salaries more
importantly they feel they're
contributing to a better world but they
have a long road ahead the goal is to
plant a billion trees by 2020 they've
currently reached 7.6 million they're
constantly updating the tally new
reforestation projects are beginning to
take off in several parts of Africa the
Assam bara mountains of northeastern
Tanzania are another example Peter
returned from the region just a few days
ago the Friends of to Samara mountains
this small local company day contacted
us explaining that I've planted half a
million trees last year but they cooked
much much more together with all the
local farmers they're working with and
they're planting local trees in
biodiversity hotspot that is very
precious so we got to know each other
better and together we worked on a
contract and now we're going to plant 3
million trees with them still this year
in Tanzania in use and our mountains
in recent decades large areas of the
ancient forests have been destroyed it
costs just 30 cents to plant a tree here
even so it'll take many more internet
searches and advertising clicks before
everything is green and lush again
[Music]